ми безмежно вдячні вам за допомогу за те
що ви
переймаєтеся нашими пацієнтами і
особливо жителями Ковеля і Ковельського
району і сусіднього району і я так думаю
що ваша допомога сторицею вам вернеться
і членам вашого фонду Дуже дякуємо фонду
Порошенка за надану благодійну допомогу
зсідним матеріалом для апаратів шв це
ендотхальні трубки аспіраційні три
кисневі маски які при до апаратів швl в
період карантину Ми дуже потребуємо цих
необхідних матеріалів так що дуже
Дякуємо На сьогоднішній день ця допомога
яка Ми отримали це для нас дуже важно
дуже вчасно і дуже необхідно це саме
головне в захисті медичного працівника
це мати такий костюм для того аби вчасно
і правильно надавати медичну допомогу
щире Дякую вам всім за те що
переймаєтесь нашими проблемами вони
зараз будуть передані ці костюми в
інфекційне відділення де естьсть
пацієнти і естьсть медики які дуже
нуждаються в цьому
[музика]
всьому засобів захисту їх мало не буде
так що ми дуже вам вдячні за допомогу
яка сьогодні прийшла тому що саме
сертифіковані засоби це дуже важливо
медики мають бути впевнені в тому що це
дійсно справжній
захист
Ми отримали благодійну допомогу от фонда
Петра Порошенка представники привезли
нам на сьогоднішній день дуже потрібні
захисні костюми в яких наш персонал може
працювати з пацієнтами які хворі або з
підозрою на ковід-19 пацієнтів може бути
з кожним днем більше більше більше
поэтому захисні костюми інше обладнання
яке потрібне воно дійсно якби потрібне в
тій прогресії в якій будуть надходити
хворі допомога архи важлива тому що на
сьогоднішній день Ну Ми прекрасно
розуміємо все те що ми маємо Воно швидко
фактично використовується і Я безмежно
щиро вдячний за ті речі які дійсно
робляться на сьогоднішній день десь
відкидаються абсолютно всякі політичні
аспекти а все вкладається відповідно в
людей в боротьбу з тим невидимим вологом
я ми маємо на сьогоднішній день тому
щиро дякую вам за
таку Прекрасну допомогу от саме така
допомога вона сприяє тому що наші
працівники будуть
захищені Ми дуже вдячні за дарунок нашій
лікарні нашій люди потребують цих
костюмів вони забезпечать надійний
захист від коронавірусної
інфекції
[музика]
по бюджетным программам очень сложно
ремонтировать любую технику тем более
такую технику как эта более того она ещё
усложнилась тем что фирма которая их
раньше ремонтировала у нас ушла с рынка
Украины мы когда обратились к фонду
Петра
порошенкомы нам сразу удалось найти
понимание мы отправили аппараты прошло
буквально там чуть-чуть больше двух
недель и уже аппараты в исправ Іль
находиться з Спасибо
[музика]
большое на сьогоднішній день медики
мають і респіратори і засоби
індивідуального захисту і костюми і
маски і Я вдячний благодійникам які нас
підтримують і дають нам по можливості їм
легше ее купити ніж за бюджетні кошти
ми зараз сюди привезли партію костюмів з
Китаю від фонду Петра Порошенка
європейської
солідарності Також ми привезли захисні
окуляри Це окуляри які мають чотири
клапани вони є повністю захищені ми
переконані що сьогодні ці засоби дадуть
можливість зберегти і захистити
лікарів дякуючи меценатам благодійникам
ми
маємо таку гарну важливу допомогу і наш
персонал на сьогоднішній день є
захищений тудає маски шапки респіратори
костюми так що нам це дуже потрібно то
костюми До речі до речі дуже гарні тому
що вони мають запаяні шви бачите тоє
костюми які відповідають всім стандартам
захисту дуже гарні костюми Дуже дякуємо
ці апарати вкрай потрібні тому що на
жаль ми не могли забезпечити наше
інфекційни відділеннями апаратами
штучної вентиляції а тим більше такого
класу тому що ці апарати - це апарати
експертного класу ми можемо надавати
медичну допомогу дітям ковід-інфікованим
до року маленьким
дітям дякуючи фонду і допомозі фонду 4
Нам вдалося відремонтувати апарати оди
наразі чекає ще
ремонт Олексійович ми від імені нашої
команди від імені лікарні Та й хотів би
сказати від імені всіх дітей
Житомирської області то тому що значна
частина цих дітей лікується в нас Ми
хочемо подякувати вам за ту величезну
роботу яку ви проводите за допомогу всім
нам лікарям і не тільки допомогу
матеріальну і за допомогу яку ви
морально надаєте от навіть цей приїзд
колег ваших народних
депутатів говорить про те що ми не одні
що ми не не Залишені Що що Про нас
думають що наші інтереси
відстоюють Дякую вам за це в від
колективу і від пацієнтів від
наших
[музика]